Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my brand new spider-man
movie video Sony and Marvel just
announced a couple new spider-man
spin-off movies so we'll break it down
and how it all ties together with venom
and Tom Hollands spider-man in the MCU
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for other
spider-man spin-off movies on the video
we are slowly going full live-action
spider-verse with all the stuff that
they have planned so just going down the
list starting with number 5 Sony and
Marvel announced that they're working to
expand the spider-verse of Marvel
spider-man movies beyond venom Morbius
and the other sinister six characters
solo movies that Sony has planned right
now all these are loosely tied together
with Tom Hardy's venom because venom is
sort of the first big spider verse movie
that Sony did and because of what
they've done recently in the last year
with the new sharing deal also connected
to Tom Hollands MCU spider-man they nest
a whole bunch of spin-off movies last
year there was even a mystery spider-man
movie that was coming out next year til
the virus hit and they delayed it but
now we have confirmation on what two of
those big movies are going to be one of
them is way bigger than the other though
so the smaller one this morning that
they just confirmed was a jackpot solo
movie I know a lot of you who may not
have read every single spider-man comic
book are like who the hell is jackpot
so for jackpot is a female spider-man
comic book character who showed up as a
gene therapist doing research he's
exposed this will sound familiar to
something called lot 777 a virus that
rewrites her DNA in her cells so it's a
little bit like Spider Man comic book
origins bitten by a radioactive spider
changes his DNA the original jackpot was
named Sarah Arendt
but then there was a second one that
took the mantle for a little while and
then the original one came back I'm
assuming that the movie is going to be
based on the original version of jackpot
she winds up getting super-strength she
starts to bring a comic book suit like
this fighting crime they didn't say
exactly what kind of movie is going to
be but it feels like a little bit
smaller than what you would expect from
say like a big venom or a traditional
MCU spider-man film it's being written
by Marc Guggenheim that was also part of
the announcement this morning he's
working on a bunch of movies for Sony
he's even working on a live act
Gantz movie that Sony is trying to do
based on the anime and the manga moving
on to the next big spider-man spin-off
movie they announced three the other one
is much bigger in my opinion earlier
this week you probably saw the news they
announced the spider-man Madame web
movie officially we knew that they were
planning on doing Madame web at some
point they announced that a couple years
ago we just didn't know when it was
actually going to happen across other
dimensions dimensions that are strange
reflections of our own a past unlike
ours a present-day sink and a distant
future and here's why I think this one
is going to be a much bigger movie than the
other Sony spin-off movies because she
is an important character in the spider
verse she has crazy powers most of you
remember her from the 1990s
spider-man animated series or from the
spider-verse comics she's able to travel
the web of life and destiny at will time
space the multiverse but they're saying
that the movie is being made for
Charlize Theron she would be the Madame
web furiosa Madame web as cool as that
is dear Charlize Theron might be playing
a version of Madame web a lot of you are
scratching your heads going wait a
minute doesn't Madame web look more like
Aunt May's and she's supposed to be an
old lady within that announcement the
people behind the project acknowledge
that because they're planning for
Charlize Theron it would obviously be
very different version of Madame web
from the comics so they did say that it
might wind up being a more straight-up
Spider Woman type of movie even though
she wouldn't be playing Jessica drew
Spider Woman or even spider-gwen for
that matter
although Charlize Theron would kill as
an older version of spider-gwen
but you have to imagine that once they
do eventually get to a live-action
spider-gwen she'll probably be a
teenager just like Tom Hollands
spider-man hey guys I'm from another
dimension I mean another another
dimension okay then
so right now it's still a little unclear
as to how much they're going to change
live-action Madame web but it will be
obviously a very different take than the
classic version of the character if they
can lock her down Charlize Theron would
be a huge get for the spider-verse of
movies she's legit and she has good
on-screen chemistry with Tom Hardy their
venom everybody remembers them from Mad
Max fury road so number two in terms of
Tom Hollands spider-man in the MCU
connections back when we found out about
Marvel and
his plans for crossing over MCU
spider-man with the venom movies and
then the separate sinister six movie
plans with Sony the first big thing
people assumed when Kevin Feige said the
words spider-man and multiverse in the
same sentence was Madame web using her
powers to take spider-man from the MCU
version of Earth to an alternate
universe potentially where Tom Hardy's
venom character and all the Sony movies
existed and that would just be the easy
solution for explaining how everything
works because Kevin Feige made it seem
like he didn't really want venom in the
MCU or all as soon as other spin-off
movies like Morbius
well those movies will all take place in
the world that we are now creating for
for you know for Peter Parker but it
will still all be in the same world and
they will be connected to each other as
well so there is a chance that and Tom
Holland a Spider Man will pop up
somewhere oh there's always a chance I
think what
but back around d23 after they cleared
up all their spider-man sharing business
Marvel and Sony released their official
plan for how these crossovers are going
to work between the MCU characters any
spider-man related movies that Sony does
including the venom movies and any other
Marvel movies ik controls are allowed to
reference anything from the MCU
spider-man's history in the MCU movies
that means stuff like Avengers infinity
war the snap Avengers endgame the blip
all the stuff they've done in the
spider-man MCU movies with the sinister
six characters even the events of
Captain America Civil War but that's
pretty much it that's the limit so when
Tom Holland shows up with venom on
screen they won't start talking about
the events of the Black Panther movie or
the events of Thor Ragnarok or guardians
of the galaxy just spider-man related
stuff in other spider-man comic book
characters like vulture Mysterio you get
the idea
probably Tom Hollands spider-man making
a whole bunch more pop-culture movie
references when he's with venom use it
the picture of this infinity war scene
when he's with Iron Man but it's Tom
Hardy's venom standing here trying to
follow him as he's making all these
movie references and on the other side
of that with the MCU spider-man movies
it's the same thing with Tom Holland
being able to reference anything that
happens with the venom movies when he's
in those or any of the sinister six
movies the spider-man 4 movie that we
found out about a little while ago is a
good example that I'd say spider-man 3
but I think spider-man 3 is going to be
released before a lot of the huge Tom
hoenn Tom Hardy venom crossover stuff
happens so a lot of that probably won't
come up yet but it's being released
after venom 2 so just wait to see what
happens with that because we got all
that spider-man stuff in the Morbius
trailer and there are obviously
potential spider-man Easter eggs and
scenes that they have for venom to maybe
just teasers for stuff that's coming
down the road but number one right
now the earliest I'm expecting to see
legit Tom hall and Spider Man cameo
scenes are maybe maybe small chance of a
venom to post-credits scene there have
been rumors for a long time about Sony
trying to get him to cameo in that movie
now that they delay the movie till next
year they have that much extra time to
film cameo scenes with Tom Holland but
as for the other new spider-man spin-off
movies like bat and webbing jackpot is
more likely you'd see venom Easter eggs
and some may be small
my main Easter eggs in the background
I'm not expecting a lot of Tom Holland
actual cameo scenes and crossovers in
those movies the one real big exception
to that would be the potential sinister
six movie that they're building up to
but in terms of other big spider-man a
live-action spider-verse movies that
they have planned right now there's the
Kraven the hunter solo movie a silk solo
movie a Night Watch movie and then
obviously the sinister six team up movie
so just don't expect Tom Holland to
start cameo in ten different Sony movies
all of a sudden it's just going to be the
biggest movies because even having him
show up in a venom movie is supposed to
be a really really special rare thing
but if Sony can actually pull off a real
live-action spider-verse movie real
spider-verse
that's when you start to see all these
characters that they're trying to do
solo movies for crossing over and
obviously potential for Andrew Garfield
and Tobey Maguire spider-man to come
back and get stars that's the real
attraction of a live-action spider-verse
movies they get Toby and Andrew Garfield
to come back but everyone let me know in
the comments if they're actually able to
lock down Charlize Theron is Madame web
do you want to see Tom Hollands
spider-man crossover with her character
at some point hey yeah you I'm talking
to you you piece of I'm going to kick
your ass personally just because they
had so much chemistry in Mad Max fury
road I would be totally happy if they
just did venom Madame web crossover but
if we get any other big news about
Sony's spider-man's spin-off movies of
course I'll do videos about that now
that things are slowly starting to
return to normal through the second half
of the year we'll start to get more big
news about the Marvel in the spider-man
movies so there's lots of good stuff
coming up congratulations Jimmy Peterson
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details
everyone click here for that crazy
Justice League Snyder cut announcement
turns out it's real and click here for
my brand-new Marvel Ghost Rider movie
project breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stas safe
I'll see you guys tonight!